Tim Kurkjian he'll be joining Carl
Ravich the rest of the ESPN baseball
tonight team they return to regular
nightly edition throughout the baseball
postseason and Tim Kirchen joining us
from the mojit mothership hi Timmy how
are you I'm great dan how you doing I'm
doing okay oh all right where are you
going to be watching the games today
well I'm gonna be in studio today truth
be told I'd rather be at a game but when
you're in studio you get to watch every
pitch thrown of every game which I will
do today and therefore I will at least
have a working knowledge of what's going
on in all the series and I get to watch
games on TV I'll be sitting next to
Eduardo Perez which is a treat so it's
the second best thing to actually being
at one of the games
the Brewers put away the Rockies are we
are we rooting for the Brewers because
it's new and kind of a neat cute story
or should we be looking at the Brewers
as they are the best team in the
national league or maybe it's both it's
a little of both
I'm not sure they're the best team
internationally because I still need to
see what the Dodgers are gonna do from
here I still think the Dodgers have the
most talented roster but there there is
nothing cute about the Brewers day and
they are relentless their bullpen is
stunningly good 189 IRA since the start
of September that's almost a run lower
than any other team in the major league
they bring wave after wave of hard
throwing relievers out of the bullpen
they can hit the ball out of the
ballpark they have a great infield
defense they've won 11 games in a row
they are really good right now but that
Dodger team is is really good also and I
think we're gonna get an LCS where the
two best teams in the league are playing
which is all we can ever ask but you get
these teams and it just feels like
there's fate I don't want to say destiny
but it feels like the Brewers have that
going this year yeah I agree with you
Dan
I saw them quite a bit at the end of the
season I did their game 163 against the
Cubs
and I don't care how corny this sounds
there
something special going on there and
maybe this sounds ridiculous maybe it's
the manager
maybe it's Craig Counsell Mark Grace
wants to he went to Notre Dame Mark
Grace once described him as Rudy with
talent not two championship teams in his
career he understands the job of
managing he's a bill walky guy managing
the Waukee Brewers he told me that four
years ago Hank Aaron was making a speech
on stage in Milwaukee and he called
Craig Counsell who was working for the
club but not as the manager in C Craig
you have to come up here so Craig
Counsell said I can't go up there you're
you're Hank Aaron I came to get you
you're Hank Aaron I'm Craig Counsell and
then hey Garrett started asking him
questions and counsel told me oh my gosh
possible so that's who we're dealing
with as the manager and that kind of
communication and that kind of everyday
man that he is I think really aids in
how well this team is doing
Clayton Kershaw said he had nothing to
prove didn't have to prove anything to
anybody I felt like he still maybe he
had to something to prove to himself
whether he'd admit to it or not he was
brilliant in his last outing but does
Clayton Kershaw have something to prove
when it comes to the postseason well I
really don't think so Dan I don't that
narrative is over however we know how
this works you have to win the World
Series you have to win a big game to
help win the World Series before you're
not just going to be anointed as a good
postseason player but as one of the
greatest pitchers of all times you have
to do something in October and help your
team win the World Series is that fair
of course it's not but that starts the
other night was brilliant
I think he's got more of that in him and
I think he needs just to have that one
seminal moment where you know he pitches
a great game and the Dodgers go on to
win the World Series which is is the
possibility this year
Houston's in I don't know if they're
underdogs
they're just underappreciated and here
they're leading Cleveland to oh and
three today in Cleveland assess this
Astros team this year as opposed to last
year's team
well it's potentially even better
because they have Gerrit Cole who just
had a 12 strikeouts no walking he was in
a brilliant game he was bright Tom
Seaver had a 13 strikeout no walk game
and Cole just put up the second best one
of those it was ridiculous how good he
was and he's added to the team this year
I just worry that offensively they're
not the team they were last year Carlos
Correa has bad back he hasn't been the
same player but that little Alex Bregman
guy has become player on the team Danny
in the postseason this five foot ten
inch third baseman has two homers off of
Chris Sale one off Kershaw one off
Kenley Jansen one off Trevor Bauer and
one off Corey Kluber in the postseason
alone when the game gets the biggest
when the situation gets the biggest
that's when that little guy is at his
best and man has he been great and I
think he adds a little extra to that
Astro team going into more games here
the postseason because he's even better
than he was at this time last year
Yankees Red Sox tonight at Yankee
Stadium advantage is well I got to think
it's the Yankees because they're home
and they've got Louie Severino who's a
19 game winner and is starting to find
the great stuff that he had the first
three months of the season and I think
more than anything they're starting to
hit on that Yankee team Dan we've been
over this before one through nine please
tell me your team that can beat you with
the homerun ball like this team Ken it's
the greatest home run hitting team in
baseball history and now Gary Sanchez
the catcher is that such a miserable
year is really starting to swing it so I
think that gives the advantage to the
Yankees but anyone who things on the red
sucker big big trouble hasn't watched
the Red Sox all year this is going to be
a great series when I just think he's
definite to go five game
yeah the pitching with the Red Sox you
know sale we weren't sure about because
he loses velocity this time of the year
you know David Price is really the
conundrum for this team
he's a conundrum for all of us and that
this makes absolutely no sense he was so
good for about two and half months to
start the second half that you just
thought he was a given going into the
playoffs and yet
Yankees clearly have his number he has
terrible trouble at Yankee Stadium and
now they're gonna have to figure out how
to beat the Yankees with David Price
still in the rotation he's gonna have to
pitch again or baby they'll just use
them out of the bullpen I don't know but
that has to get fixed if they're gonna
get past the Yankee great stuff is
always Tim tell Carl and everybody else
Edoardo that we settle oh and have fun
today okay that's uh Tim Kirchen
baseball analyst for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]